hey [ __ ] welcome to another episode
of hey [ __ ] and I just want to
introduce my [ __ ] to the other
[ __ ] okay I am [ __ ] Nikki limo
oh I'm bows Oh big [ __ ] bows a [ __ ]
TIFF I'm little this [ __ ] cuz I'm not
really a [ __ ] but I'm really a big
[ __ ] she's so tiny I am small my name
is Gigi oh it's my name's G oh yeah I'm
a [ __ ] it feels so weird to do this
episode right now cuz I normally wear
headphones but yeah i can't hear like
your beautiful deep blushes voices right
now so i just want to point it out
because i know the comments already oh
yeah by the way all the people in the
comments of our youtube that are like
why doesn't Nikki wear headphones it's
because not because I'm too cool for
headphones but because if I hear my
voice in my own ears I forget what I'm
talking about
god I'm so thrown off I thought it was
just cuz that good ass hair leave that
hair do you have a haircare tutorial on
my youtube channel you should ohh what
its youtoo.com slash Nikki Liam oh yeah
no big deal and mine is just cuz I got a
bunch of piercings on my earring it
[ __ ] hurts but that's neither here
nor there but I do want to talk about
nudes today yeah this was requested a
lot by bows okay you guys know and this
was like this was like a few months or
weeks back that there was this whole
controversy where like Bella Thorne had
leaked her own nudes yeah and Whoopi
Goldberg hair something to say what she
just she did it she she did it guys if
you guys didn't know her Twitter yeah if
you didn't hear the backstory basically
some hackers threatened to leak her
nudes and she interned as a bit of a
Power Move decided to take her own nudes
however I will say this exact thing
happened from a twitch streamer named
perco schipperkes something two months
prior she did it first Bella you copied
her shots fired but I mean the thing is
and then like be called her out you said
yeah we'll be like called her out and
was like what is my morning voice today
I don't know what this is I feel like I
sound like a STONER
but welcome to the club everyone thinks
I must
and I don't smoke continue I but but
yeah so you know what we called her out
and it was like basically she said if
you're a celebrity you shouldn't be
taking nudes and there was a lot of
controversy about that so I wanted to
pick your opinions yeah I wanna hear
your opinion well I don't know maybe we
should like start down the line yeah we
do this we do this whoo and I'm gonna
follow Nikki's bullet points right now
she's nerd I like to just go with the
flow but Nikki's really cute and super
organized so she has my Gold Logie oh
yeah you go with the flow in a very
organized fashion yeah bullet points oh
I like when we bring up a topic that we
have like flow with that okay first of
all my first bullet point is have any of
you ever given your nudes out to anybody
set nudes always every single [ __ ]
time always really I love it cuz I never
have so like tell me about that like
what me do Boulder wait let's hear wait
like who's born again yeah okay Nikki
are you four okay so I have so I'm mixed
so I mixed because yeah yeah in every
way so I have never sent nudes out I
will never send nudes out I'm so
paranoid about anything getting hacked
or leaked or whatever if I choose to do
a movie where like I choose to do nudity
that's different than somebody finding
my nude photos that were intended for my
privacy and you just feel like damn that
was for me yeah exactly
however I don't judge anybody who does
do it and I think they have full rights
to do that and they shouldn't be worried
about people so you're against would be
calling out Bella yeah but we'll get
there Oh we'll get there what about you
don't leave me hanging pose we're always
together dude I don't take nude photos I
did not distribute new
you're not together I'm I'm pretty
strong about this but I will get this
strong you know in that you also don't
believe other people should either cuz
she's more on the like flexible yeah
you're judging me we're gonna get into
it I'm so excited this is why I wanted
to argue with y'all yeah um you know
it's a little bit of my Christian guilt
and some of my experiences hmm I'll get
there okay and how do we get there like
I want to get there now I was gonna say
yeah we'll get there
well for me I've never distributed
actual nude photos Oh distributed like
you print it you go to [ __ ] FedEx
like literally texting it to someone or
emailing back in the day no I even did
that aim yeah I never I never people
sitting nudes Overeem oh yeah yeah I
never did that oh I did so ass photos
does that count as nude yes cuz it's
just one part what's are okay they don't
even censor them on TV
okay well Mickey are you really against
nudes I I told you I'm very neutral
beause okay so I personally feel like my
butt has been [ __ ] everywhere
on the internet because it used to be in
thumbnails like short shorts short like
booty things and so I'm like [ __ ] a
butts a butt like everyone's showing
their butt like a people you're showing
your boat with no underwear with a thong
no no no no plain so did a little just
give it all away it's there I did a
playboy shoot not nude but it was like
when playboy actually went to different
youtubers and like we did our own like
playboy shoot based on our personalities
and so I was like a cat lady but sexy
and then like yeah my butt I saw those
there but like you go on a on the beach
and people are wearing less than that so
that to me that's not nude to me
full-frontal is new yeah that's that's
that's what I'm talking about cuz I've
done like sexier kind of things
give me some give me some examples like
you know lower
my shirt oh no or like I'll be in some
lingerie and I'll take photos of ready
like though cuz lingerie can also be
very like nipple me hovered up ya know
you can see nipples through lingerie
know the ones I had it wasn't like see
through you can see nipples through my
shirt now go to YouTube would look at
the exposure yeah but yeah so I would
take those like sexier photos but not
actually like just you know showing
nipple or showing anything like spread
open or nothing anything I would dude
yeah oh please tell us like what you
said all of it everything Wow Amy
requests yeah let's get a poll here
nobody would see these were only with
guys that I was like having a serious
relationship with so when I was dating I
maybe I did that like once or twice I'm
like I'm gonna show you what I got under
here oh but it was the underwear thing
it wasn't like it wasn't like completely
nude yeah I never sent them but I did do
it's a nude shoot for yourself no no
once with a guy that I was with and so
he actually did take photos of me and
that was the only time ever
until this day I'm just like oh god who
has those photos okay
it's okay okay but you know what
technically though I was I was underage
Wow
this is your like mysterious and like
kind of like hehe I don't play and then
your damn that's really sandal it that's
really sex yeah I mean but I don't know
like he told me he deleted them they
never do know they know that they're
still there
I know oh I think before we get into
like everything I think it's a general
disclaimer we probably all want to throw
out there like we're also not like if if
like snapchat or anything is your
artistry if you run an only fence or
something I don't think it's in the same
category for this you know this is more
just like girls like in our personal
experience like us like sending out to
like a significant other and that's your
coin girl get your yeah also not yucking
anyone's young okay yeah yeah sharing
our own personal experience but you I
want to know like yeah what do you guys
out there have your nudes and where can
we find them let me see let me see
listening Khan so I've had let me see
one two three
for like less than five guys yeah yeah
okay there were all boyfriends wait I'm
so glad you're the only one here that
has sent them yeah wait Oh what is it do
free does it give you kind of a thrill
like yes yeah okay but one of my one of
my turn-on triggers if you will I got
that from Shannon's oh yeah desire book
Shannon Boudreaux yeah there you go mine
is being desired so as soon as I know
someone is designed like someone's like
straight up like I want you like you're
the [ __ ] bitter Glaber then that for
me is like the number one turn-on
trigger for me so I think I would put
that out there cuz I'm like I want you
to want yeah and tell me how much you
want this so like that's what it just
gave me a thrill and a ride especially
when they're not there with you yeah
that's why I wanted to know that's the
reason why I never sent them everything
though cuz I'm like now you gotta come
again
I know you got a word for this I think
for me because I was just under house
arrest with my parents they couldn't
ever get it so I was like damn I got to
get my thrill on because I have a 10
o'clock curfew at 25 always the girls
have the most rules put on them go crazy
yeah don't put rules on your daughters
guys I know what else you want to know I
want to know how the guys reacted they
send nudes back to you do you hate but I
didn't want them yeah I'm like here just
like like give me the compliments like
tell me how [ __ ] gorgeous and the
goddess or whatever I am yeah and then I
would be like are you gonna are you
gonna jack off to this yeah even that
just that it turns you on
have you knowing that they're jacking
off yeah sure absolutely wouldn't it
turn you on like if they sent you a
photo of their hard dick looking at you
oh then that's 30 pence yeah it depends
I think I would rather see a video at
that point yeah I don't know you just
you were just like just drop straight to
the video and I'm like I've received
videos before and I never wanted them no
I didn't want them either so it tip it
sounds like you do like nudes from guys
then like are you dudes from guys no oh
my god we need to talk about guy nude
studio yes I do not like them
no but if someone that you love yeah
yeah okay no yeah so like if if I'm
sexting Casey which we don't you really
I don't send it so I'm like alright well
I mean we have like we use words we
don't use photos yeah what send me
something I would have receive it I'd be
like cool that's dope
you got that hard dick cause of me yeah
girl like a pic like a video of you like
jacking off in she text back cool
oh that's dope you got hard because of
me no I keep going like oh how can I
make you harder she didn't see cool
she's like god damn baby very very cool
what can I do to make you Jack you know
cuz then that's when I go to like hey
how about we FaceTime now and we get to
just see each other
dance oh my god and that's what I'm down
to do not to actually send them and then
they actually have this within their
position that for me yeah the word they
could totally do that but it's just
video mental for me yeah they have
ownership of it then I know and it's
like you don't that's mine I I get to
keep ownership of it so both have has
anyone ever requested nudes from you and
you just straight up or like no yeah
it's hot as [ __ ] well yep all right Geo
how are you buddy Quan damn it just say
although we started Hicks on me a lot
going to the spa get like totally naked
and I had one point where I was like in
the showers I was having a nice time I
happen to look behind me Gio
whatever you're thinking she looked like
yes just whatever egde I'm pretty sure
she was like pouring a thing of water on
her with I love that you saw me but I'm
literally with my monkey knows me I went
shaved down there and you're like oh
you're really going for it me I you know
I I'm actually with you on the butt
pictures okay happy because you have a
beautiful bubble yeah you should thank
you I show it off you know I gave you
that but to show it share with the world
for me personally and I think some
people will relate to it my lack of it
my not wanting to send you ins is a from
Christian guilt once it's there it's
there forever like your [ __ ] I disagree
I was raised Catholic but go on you did
go to a did you go to a church where
they would lock the doors if people
didn't pay enough tides no but yeah I
think
there go one way or the other where
you're like I have too much guilt like I
need to stay good girl or you're like
[ __ ] that I hate being held down by the
man and they keep going like rebellions
it's kind of in the back of my head but
you know for one of two reasons a when I
was like 15 or 16 I was dating an older
guy and we took some photos together and
my mother found them I was like fifteen
and I have never felt so much weight
what were the photos remember I think
you don't remember yours you better
remember this photo this was like 12
years ago so it was taken with an actual
like camera camera like 12 years ago
that's 2007 I remember okay because
maybe her guilt is because it were
really crazy like no no I think it was
it was like mostly lingerie but it was
still like I was 15 I should not have
been say oh and my mom was on my
computer and she found the photos and
when she called me in I've never felt so
much shame in my life so it's a little
of that and then also another thing that
happened was did you guys ever hear of a
website called was anyone up from 2010
no it was one of the first nude websites
for revenge porn it was started by a
hunter more when I when we were 17 my
best friend got her news posted to the
site and we didn't know that because
this was all so new that we could have
just said she's underage take that down
but instead her nudes circulated through
a town like very early in the Internet
age everyone was like you know calling
her name's about LA and so I as my best
friend I kind of like lived vicariously
through her and I saw everything that
she went through so for me personally I
saw you know 12 years ago how it made me
feel ten years ago how it made a friend
of mine feel and so it kind of [ __ ] it
up for me but with but yes with what's
in 2016 I took this butt picture and it
was Bob it was a it was a booty popping
you know it was a great pick Coco could
paint the picture it was very I mean it
was I mean I seen her butt butt and it
was like black underwear and like
red sheets that were like silky great
photo here's the problem so with my
current boyfriend this is the only new
dish that I've taken in the last five
years and so the guy that I'm seeing now
when we first started talking I was like
here's a little sexy picture of my butt
and he told me later he was like when he
went to save it tell me until you're
later that he knew because he bucking he
was like so that night I went to Jack ah
and I opened the picture I haven't had
any good experiences with sending news
[Laughter]
so speaking of that we are very thankful
for our sponsor today's stitch fix which
is an online personal styling service
mmm I actually have used this service
for a few years and I really like that
you fill out a survey in the beginning
and you kind of like they ask you about
your style preferences and what your
what kind of looks that you like they
kind of show you pictures of what are
you more drawn to and you click on that
yeah exactly and then at the end of it
they assess every all of your answers
and they basically make a catered style
thing let me read it for ya exactly and
so then you get assigned to a stylist
and the stylist speaks directly to you
they message you and they kind of ask
you if like you're looking for skirts
right now or maybe you want seasonal
stuff or maybe you have an event coming
up like a wedding or a birthday or
whatever and you get to tell them like
all the stuff you you want and or you
like surprise me and then they send you
a box and it's full on all the clothes
that you would ever want but maybe you
didn't think to pick out yeah like
accessories and like shoes yeah that's
that all of that stuff and I think it's
really cool because you know
a lot of times you want to look more
stylish you want an updated wardrobe but
you don't know where to start you know
you go to the mall and you're just like
overwhelmed by clothes and so having
basically a personal stylist for not the
cost of a personal stylist is really
cool and you can you can pick like how
often you want your boxes to come and if
you don't need to skip a month or
whatever you couldn't do that like maybe
you're like I haven't good on clothes
this month but it's really cool and then
basically you try on everything that
they send you and then you keep what you
like you send the rest back and you only
pay for what you keep how easy yeah
Jenny nice know that 70% of women are
not dressing the best that they could
like you know clothes that match their
body and their style that's that I just
made that statistic up but if I believed
I believed if it doesn't fall into that
category and not that's why that's why
before I even used my stitch fix
subscription I was ready for it to come
I was binge watching YouTube videos of
other girls like getting their clothes
trying them on like deciding what
they're gonna stick with it's addictive
like watch some YouTube videos before
you say yeah you're gonna be so stoked
waiting for your box totally and there's
actually no subscription required so you
can pick between automatic shipments or
you can only get new pieces on demand
shipping exchanges and returns are
always free and it's actually really
cool because they give you the label and
you just drop it off at UPS you can ask
to have them pick it up I do that all
the time
yeah it's so convenient plus then you
get the styling so the styling fee
there's a 20 L or styling fee but it
gets deducted from whatever you bought
so it's not like not an extra cost get
started today at 6 H fix comm slash b
tch and get an extra 25% off when you
keep everything in your box
that's stitch fix comm slash b tch
stitch fix comm slash b tch all right so
it looks like we fixed that [ __ ] so for
you guys that say how do you guys
finesse your way out of sending those
news somebody else okay so I'll tell you
because Steve requests them all the time
and
and he says he's gonna buy a Polaroid
camera cuz the compromise that we made
he's like would you let me keep a
Polaroid photo of you nude and I was
like yeah okay that can't get hacked
into so he can keep that but in the baby
was gonna lose it it's true what if he
takes a picture of the photo oh I just
hooked it up for sale in her house okay
use our house okay good that's the thing
about having a very predictable man he's
always in the office so it's probably
somewhere in his office okay good anyway
but in his office before we got to this
compromise the most sexy compromise that
I had and this was this is the very
beginning of our relationship is our six
month of ursery I did this little thing
because he was actually on a road trip
with his family and so he was gonna be
gone for two weeks including our
six-month / Surrey Oh six-month bursary
so I had made little envelopes for him
to open along the way on his road trip
so unless you you're hungry opened this
one and it would be like a Panda Express
gift card or like a Taco Bell gift card
because you couldn't decide if I was
Asian or Mexican like for whatever you
think I am at the time and and then like
it was really personal like that and
then at the end he's a huge Colts fan
and I dress I took one of his jerseys
like his cold stir ZZZ and it was just
that and underwear and the player which
I forget what player was Marvin
something I'm sorry I forget the
player's name but it was Marvin
something and I one of the cards said
open this when you're feeling feisty or
whatever and then it told him to like
text me basically like hey this was
Marvin so-and-so text me I got a message
for you and then he would text me and
I'm like oh hey what's up I got your
girl Nikki here and she's wearing my
Jersey better come get her just like me
like on a bunch of really sexy pictures
with his Jersey and I I put that [ __ ] on
self-timer and I had but it was like my
butt and then like with the Jersey and
then it's like a man mouth and stuff not
nude but very sexy and he did tell me he
had quite a jacking off session and it
was very hard to do with all his family
there oh yeah Wow okay so as a
compromise
romantic yeah I like that romantic thing
sentimental things
that's cute I'm raunchy bro I'm raunchy
Jean what's your what's your okay what's
your battle plan if your like your nudes
got leaked I would probably do the bella
thorne thing where I'm like cool there
yeah like that mean I just would I would
accept it cuz I'm just like well I kind
of put it out there and now that it
happens on my damnit that sucks that it
happened I'm not gonna be mortified I'm
just gonna be like enjoy and I mean it
sucks that like it's your it's a human
body like yeah it's like you're it's
your body why is that shameful to me it
even though I particularly don't want it
out there unless I chose to be in a role
and that's really what it was is like oh
I want it if I do show nudity to the
public I want it to be in an acting role
or something like that but like I don't
think it should be shameful for people
that want to do that and and for people
that want to keep it private I don't
think that they should be shamed if that
gets hacked into and leaked it's 100%
the people the [ __ ] [ __ ] that
hack the phone yeah and I think you
should be like to do it with Whoopi
because of that fact how she was kind of
like blaming it on thought bella thorne
yeah of like going in on the guy who
ended up leaking or like threatening her
blackmailing her to leak it but for me
the whole shame thing because I I am
like really protective of my body and
it's because I've had experiences in the
past especially and you know Mexican
culture guys tend to be like real what's
the proper word I don't know wait you
know what I'm trying to say but they're
more like a silly I'm flirty
yeah yeah yeah so like they're at least
where I grew up in the people I was
around they were just very like they
would kind of pretty much undress me
with their eyes and when I was a little
girl too so from a very young age I've
always felt like this is you know like
it's without my permission it has been
exposed pretty much because of that
reason I was always very protective of
like I don't want like even if I had a
nude and if it got leaked that would
[ __ ] kill me like I would I could not
be strong enough like yugioh to be like
[ __ ] it enjoy that's really admirable
because that's totally something I could
not go
it feels like a violation people I think
and it is a violation I think it's
really cool to that we're having this
conversation because then you have you
know you have some people who are like
oh you shouldn't take news and then some
that say yeah it's cool but I think it
has to do with experiences you know like
you know Tiffany's that she's gone
through some bad stuff like I've gone
through some that made me feel really
deep feelings early on and it's just
kind of stuck with me and I think it has
a lot to do with experiences rather than
just like shy opinions yeah boy but it
sounds like when that thing happened to
your friend when they were French poor
and got uploaded it wasn't like oh [ __ ]
that guy it was like oh I would feel
shame if that happened to me yeah yeah
it was a lot of people that there was a
lot of people on that website that we're
getting leaked it was one of the
original ones and there was a whole lot
of legal stuff of getting it taken down
a lot of states had to enact like a
revenge porn yeah law that didn't exist
and it was because of this website
called us anyone up and I mean it was
just a very painful experience for a
seventeen year old girl to go through I
bet yeah in high school you know a bad
sex rumor can ruin you in high school I
had that happen to me you know and it
wasn't even [ __ ] true yeah but you
know to actually have those photos of
you leaked is is is incredibly painful I
was actually just watching a documentary
like yesterday about a girl named like
rehtaeh that got her nudes leaked and
she ended up killing herself at like 17
yeah like like a lot of people cannot
handle it emotionally yeah and I'm not
really sure exactly where that comes
from but I think it's for sure I mean at
least for me it's definitely because of
past experiences where I feel like I had
no control over what someone was saying
or thinking or trying to do to my body
yeah that's definitely where that comes
from because then like you end up having
you train yourself or like your your way
to protect yourself it's like sort of
associating it with shame and what it is
and also excuse me also think about it
we're all social creatures biologically
we like to be like in our groups no and
now imagine this thing gets leaked and
and the rest of the group doesn't
approve and now they're judging you and
they are trying to exclude you from this
group and now you just feel like holy
[ __ ] like nobody wants me I'm like a bad
seed and now a couple that or like on
top of that you don't know who
you don't have like your self-confidence
you're talking about when you're 17 in
the second just anyone that just doesn't
have that confidence where they're just
like like hey I'm my own person I'm
valuable like like maybe you're not my
group you know because everyone wants to
belong to something I just think like
the laws or like the with the rep the
consequences should be much harsher on
the hackers and the people that expose
this inviolate that's then it should be
on shaming the girl because yeah I think
if the laws were harsher then people
would be not as motivated to do it
because if you get caught then it's like
really sucks like you go to prison for
10 years or whatever it is like because
it isn't such a violation I mean that is
the same feeling as like you know on a
lesser scale of like yeah rape you know
because it's something that's gonna be
taken away from you right not doing it
not to like devaluate rape because
that's much higher on the scale but in
the same way of being violated yeah that
I think it's not taking us seriously in
a court of law
yes it there's nothing that can be done
about it it's not but I think now
because currently there isn't anything
happening I think that before you send
anything online whether it's not a nude
it could be like your credit card
information or you're signing up to this
new thing it's like just be very
vigilant and just be careful because
these things can't happen so I think
before clicking send or enter whatever
you just have to tie yourself like am I
gonna be okay with this cuz that's
something that I think yeah annoys me
about my mom cuz this [ __ ] still writes
checks I love my mom and call her this
but yeah she'll still write checks and
she has to personally like go to the
mailbox to like send in her mail because
she thinks someone's gonna like break
into the mill box in front of her house
that she's taking all these things into
account and yeah she's taking extra
steps but she's just like I don't want
anything to happen yeah I think keeping
that in our mind the level of which
you're not willing to exactly sacrifice
so think I'm not at all victim-blaming
in any sort of way but it's like you
should definitely be thinking about like
if I Sun enter at this moment these are
the things that I'm also gonna attract
you know happy okay let me let me
propose a devil's advocate Janerio is
like should you have to consider the
fact that you might get murdered if you
walk down the street because that's kind
of like the same but
like all do as animals though like it's
the yeah like we're all we should always
be aware of our surroundings right cuz
like I'm not saying like like you need a
prep for it and always be afraid and
feel fearful of your life yeah like if
there's like - like if there's a fork in
the road and this one's like dark as
[ __ ] and this one's lid is [ __ ] like
lettuce [ __ ] if we would all probably be
like hmmm that one looks kind of scary
let me try this
no definitely I'm just talking like what
Geo saying - is like yeah that one looks
kind of scary but geo saying well I know
I can handle that so I'm okay to go now
I'm talking about like my job interviews
on the scary road I gotta go that way or
whatever but I'm with the credit card
scenario you could you can in the back
of your head go okay if my credit card
gets stolen or the number gets stolen I
can cancel that credit card I could
order a new one yeah if your nudes get
hacked into and leaked oh right go like
leave it yeah and so that to me that's
more of a violation than like a credit
card thing or whatever yet you know your
it should have been something that was
private yeah yeah but there's way more
consequences to people that hack your
credit or that do commit fraud then
there are people that hack into people's
cell phones to get nudes yeah and I
guess going back to your thing of like
my jobs down that way and I happened for
that way like but you're mentally gonna
prepare now right totally like just in
case I do have pepper spray like you're
already going through the checklist in
your mind yeah yeah that's the best way
you can learn from experiences because
like for example when I was younger I
discovered that I was being I was being
filmed when I was out getting in the
show my god and it was obviously without
my consent and just finding this out
ever since then everywhere I go every
Airbnb I go to oh that wasn't it at
Airbnb no oh never talked about publicly
but um but yeah I just try to be really
really careful um yeah that sucks
totally something that's always just
forever in my mind and yeah like what
you were saying like Gio how you just
have to be careful because you want to
avoid
whatever has happened or what could
happen so yeah it's definitely there's a
responsibility on yourself where you
have to make sure that you you protect
yourself as much as you can even though
you can't always yeah yeah and it sounds
kind of like what you were saying like
you shouldn't have to even worry about
yeah like that shouldn't that should
never be a thing that you're you're
going back on right now and going like
[ __ ] like now I have to check every
single Airbnb or I have to be like is
there somebody filming it like that's
[ __ ] up that's why I always feel bad
for the victim or bad for the girl like
I don't ever think like well she should
have protected herself more because yeah
you shouldn't have to worry about that
even though I personally want to it just
like when I was in high school I was on
birth control plus I had condoms plus I
would use a spermicide because I
definitely didn't want to get pregnant
yeah like that was because I was scared
but there's people out there that like
they've had sex and they they got
pregnant and I don't blame them right
they just didn't know you know like and
it's it sucks and I feel like it
shouldn't
I mean pregnancy is different because
that's not someone personally attacking
you and like doing it but but like the
same thing we're like I just I just feel
like you should be able to take your top
off at the beach without someone coming
up and grabbing your titties yeah like
harassing you but unfortunately that
doesn't happen or always happen you guys
I would go to the beach take it off and
nothing happens but you could get
harassed and that really sucks and
that's why I'm like kind of like on the
fence with both of the things because I
even though I personally wouldn't do it
I wish you had that shitty you want the
toys like Geo who's like yo I want you
to desire me I wish that you were able
to do that in private without having to
worry about it yeah and if that ever did
happen to you like someone hacked into
your phone that there would be a lot of
consequences for that person yeah I like
to get their head chopped off or their
artwork chopped up what's happening over
here let's have a fun scenario right
okay let's have a fun scenario the
scenario
bouton Brooklyn what's a fun scenario um
okay so let's say someone does get
caught what's what's the [ __ ] that we do
to them wait the prison dude the thing
that stopping murder is that there's
laws against murder there's a Louie CK
bit about that but like otherwise
everyone will be murdering their you too
kind of ironic that I think what's
really interesting is like you know
there's two sides of it it's a like how
the law like takes care of things but
also how we as a society treat people
that you know that send photos of
themselves to someone they love or
someone they trust yeah and I think with
tonight's hush on both times is what we
were so afraid of was the shame and the
reaction from others like you know like
because this is this is a thing that you
should not do but it was out of my
control and it was out there but it's us
as a society that condemns it as
something that you should not but bosz
you said you had rules for nudes yeah
earlier before we started like yo I I
think there should be rules today okay
let me talk about that yes no absolutely
all right here's all right and you you
touched on this a minute ago I got two
rules I'm a fire off first one if you're
if maybe instead of saying nudes pop on
FaceTime it's a little more personal
it's like straight to the point if
they're screen-recording it or taking a
screen cap like you're gonna know you
know and then also maybe their hands
won't be on their phone who knows like
maybe we go that route but number two if
we're gonna send photos maybe you don't
put your face on it or any noticeable
tattoos you know like you kind of hard
to cover she's all putting makeup on for
three hours quarter of a nipple
cow on her arm very distinct markings on
my body you do like we're gonna know
it's you but if you don't I mean maybe
don't be so quick to put your face in it
you know like it can still be sexy its
syllable that works for people like you
but for people like me I will never send
it to someone that I don't trust and
even then right like absolutely but I'm
just saying because I'm not going those
extra steps to cover anything up or not
sure that or only do face that like I'm
like if I'm feeling it I'm sending it
you know what I mean like a man but yeah
that's that's janitrol of us the purpose
of like for Gio she wants to be desired
so it's like she wants her face and
everything to be so but I'm not just
going like I'm not doing the TIFF
distribution right so even the hottest
photos would not your room know I don't
know if you guys remember but from a
previous podcast I talked about like me
even dating someone it took three months
right because I just already have a
bunch of trust issues where I'm like I
don't trust this person to even just
waste my time on them to go on a date so
I just don't casually date and then once
I am like okay let's go on a date it's
after three months and then okay if
we're gonna get together it's always
been like like almost three year
relationship so yeah when do you send
news yeah it was about asset on the side
like how much time do you wait I think
the rest is there yeah absolutely so not
Nikki we want a time I'll probably send
a nude before I um before I have sex
with them yeah
and that's usually like three four maybe
even six months in okay that's fair we
have to take a break but I have some
thoughts on that Oh anyway let's do it
let's get some fresh takes in here oh
hello there Nikki so I want to say thank
you to our second sponsor hellofresh
and I absolutely love the service so
hello fresh makes cooking so easy so
you're gonna pick you're gonna pick the
menu of what you want to cook they pre
measure all the ingredients the
ingredients are all sourced locally
and there's gonna be no food that's
wasted because everything's all measured
out for you it's an easy directionless
for you to follow because I don't know
how to cook that well like I don't have
the Nikki or Bo's touch oh no I took me
yours I definitely use this service
before I love it yeah it's super
inspiring cuz like you get to try
different dishes that you're just at
least for me I'm super scared to even
like look at cuz I'm like oh that thing
looks complicated it's gonna have a
million ingredients that I don't know
anything about I go to the store and I
have to like I can't buy like a small
and you always forget an ingredient you
I always have to send Steve back he gets
so pissed at me I send a bag like three
different times like oops I forgot
another yeah they send you everything
and there's nothing wasted like I said
and you can decide what month that you
want to receive it there's months that
you can skip it if you're gonna go on
vacation for that whole month just be
like hey I don't want it and I like that
they have different diets so true and
terian if you're pescetarian if you're
doing paleo if you're carnivore you know
whatever you are they have different
diet choices for you yeah then they have
good meals you guys made it yes it's so
good I had the vegetarian one and there
were dishes in there I had never tried
before that we're so good yeah and you
could do like I said the family sizes so
you can have someone as small as just
for two people for people and it's super
flexible I absolutely love it if you're
someone that's busy it gets shipped to
your doorstep and they ship it with ice
so you don't have to worry like if
you're gonna be gone the whole day it's
still gonna be fresh when you get home
so um for our listeners today you guys
are getting $80 off your first break the
microphone so go to hello fresh calm
slash b tch eighty and enter b tch
eighty again that's eighty dollars off
your first month of hellofresh go to
hello fresh com that's b TCH 880 and
then enter code b TCH eighty yes all
right what do you use them
oh wait remind me what you just said um
about my rules like I don't like date
and then how long it takes me to date
yeah how long it's gonna take me to send
a nude and have sex because I was like
six months oh oh oh yes okay so I feel
like it should be the opposite where
because you said you said nudes before
you have sex I feel like
they should send you a nude before you
agree to have sex because they're
getting to see everything all the goods
ya know like even with clothes on they
could just see how big your boobs are
yeah I get to see like what I want like
all that stuff yeah we don't need to see
what's under there
until we decide to have consensual sex
and I would like to blow the merchandise
is to out there's a lot of foreplay
ambling like I mean you could feel if
their heart or not and you could feel
sighs through all that so you're gonna
feel that they're hot and you're like
first I could not reject them in person
you can tell how into you could tell the
people sex I'll just by the way they
touch yeah that's true yeah movin stuff
exactly but I'm I'm just saying if there
was logically a way I'm like well it
should be the guy sending it because we
have to see [ __ ] want it not that I want
it though either kind of be fair I feel
like there are some scenarios do you
guys actually want a nude for glucose
you do want a nude nude guy photos if
okay if there if you do receive one what
do you want to picture up I I'm a big
proponent of the like just like a little
a little below the waist like enough
that you be you say oh you don't know I
want to see the path to the dick not I
think it's Oh T get yourself but I mean
no I it's like not like it especially if
they're not wearing a shirt I'm like ooh
that's like that's a good I like that
Bo's just she told everyone that she
only dates fit guys cuz not every guy
has that actually when Steve and I first
started dating he was he had just like
lost a lot of weight cuz he was going
through a breakup and he did have the
via I guess but I personally didn't like
it because I thought he was too skinny
like he was bony where like I could feel
his pelvic bones and like if you're
skinnier than me it's it makes me really
self-conscious yeah I agree I mean
that'd be that's a good point
I like how I like Nikki's
a proposition of showing the goods
before you even get to try them because
that's true like guys good to see those
in bikinis and [ __ ] yeah anything you'd
be surprised five years to see Steve's
but why did that hi do you know because
it came on it came up with Nick it was
we forced you yeah and I was like now
that I think of it I have never seen his
butt
do you at least touch it like yeah yeah
I've touched it but he is kind of a
never-nude like have sex with when he's
fully clothed
well yeah but changed since then because
like we just switched it up because I
just never like really question it you
know how you have your sex style and
like you just kind of do the same like
moves every time well I had just gotten
used to like that's just how we do it
like because he strips me down and it's
like I like being dominated as I've
talked about before yeah so he strips me
down and then I don't get to get a say
in what he does with his clothes because
it's not ever he wants to do I like that
yeah totes fine and so I never even put
together that like oh yeah he does never
take off his shirt or his boxers and
like I never see him turn around I never
see his butt sweat boxers no yeah that's
like briefs their boxer briefs and yeah
he pulls out huh it's pretty big I kind
of like but then when he does like pull
those up then it's it's a different
sorry because it's graphic and I mom
whose mom is listening your mom you know
what her favorite is TIFF and I and I
want boses mom to like me okay she's
literally I'm so I'm so
okay marital sex okay I've never sent
two nude both mom
I barely seen my husband's but I'm just
trying to be real I was raised Catholic
okay
getting points I'm getting some [ __ ]
point you're too thirsty
no no better always been my problem
that's why I've never met my parents
favorite just saying though my mom is
literally our biggest fan my mom texted
me at like 6:30 in the morning other
issues like you guys got a shoutout from
Judy's life on YouTube was the one that
told me about that Bonnie that's so
funny you know I think these are great
solutions for people that don't feel
comfortable but want to find that sort
of yes eBridge weird like you can still
send it but feel comfortable with doing
it but for me Danna this applies I
really like that point that you make
though like what is a way to bridge that
intimacy if you can't feel comfortable
with nudes guys feel about sexting
oh I [ __ ] love it mmm you dog okay no
sexting for new why I don't know because
to me it's just unproductive I guess I
can feel you on me like I'm very like
visceral as a person so if I can't feel
you want me that was does nothing for
hardest part about being single
was like during masturbation I don't
have that wait I know I don't know what
I'm jacking off when you masturbate when
I masturbate a single I missed the
weight of a man on me I need that weight
of just being held dad sounds like the
starting a book when I masturbate
otherwise just it's just yeah it's
really hard to stay
Moyna I disagree I really enjoy
[Laughter]
that hates that I don't get it I like
moist ski everything moist is good go
ahead you like yeah like I don't know
for me on the type of person that like I
you have to court me like the entire
time like see you oh yeah like the
entire time like I should even think to
get right up so likes the sexting I was
talking about a in marriage like I still
want to take it on dates I still want to
dress up on dates though yeah you're
good yeah but so you like the sexting
yeah cuz then like it just it gets me
prepared and turned on and next time I
see him I'm gonna be all over him cuz
I'm like damn you got me there when we
were apart yeah Wow different strokes
for different folks cuz I like just
being taken out of nowhere like I'm
washing the dishes and he just swoops me
starts going at it put me up yeah but
it's painful dude yes you are yeah yeah
but that's [ __ ] I like that too I
don't like everything yeah me too I like
just being touched and I think that's
why I don't like sexting because I don't
get touched at all and to me I'd rather
be productive I'd rather be editing a
video I'd rather be doing pretty much
anything else that's productive than
like having to text you back what I'm
doing to my [ __ ] you know okay I I'm a
sexter but which is funny but like okay
so the funny thing is is that like for
me I I used to be more I used to write a
lot so so like how the romance novel
smells burnt candles burning no my no I
I send off a lot of really good
one-liners like I stand up you're doing
tweets I am I basically I'm doing sweet
sex tweet yes I just got a visit I have
a lisp I'm very self-conscious about it
you know I didn't even notice
um but no I will I will
so unlike absolutely key poses mom turn
away right now I mute it you're like AP
Calculus hard
give me some is it like that no I cannot
I cannot but I can we give it in a group
text maybe in the group to me because
we're gonna judge how old like good it
is right now and then you're really yeah
yeah you know I gotta like go get you
guys I gotta get you guys like one of
the good ones
look my my thing is is that I as a
marketer I am very in touch with the
person I'm communicating to on the other
end I know exactly what they like and I
deliver it to them so my experiences are
custom tailored based on who I'm talking
to
yeah that make sense yeah absolutely
yeah I very much know what they like and
I lean in on that this is a whole
different topic for me and maybe we'll
talk about it in a different issue but
intimacy I didn't realize that I was
blocking my own intimacy by trying to
provide what they want rather than what
I want
throughout until my mid-20s and then
when I changed slip that up or like wait
sex is supposed to be for me too and I
started really one like taking what I
wanted out of it you is when I was able
to open up and get intimate with
somebody and that's actually the first
time that I climax during sex was the
intimacy part I always just wanted to be
what they wanted which was still
enjoyable but it was very normal very
like putting off like definitely really
like oh this is what they want okay I'll
make more noises I wanted horn and you
think that that's right yeah I'm in the
same exact boat because I didn't open up
intimately until I found somebody that
liked the same exact stuff that I did
but I didn't even realize that was the
thing until we just until I was doing
what he liked and I was okay yeah yeah
yeah saying like when you find that Nash
yeah you fight but I mean you don't the
thing is is that for us maybe I don't
know if you're like me at all I didn't
go seek out what I liked at all I didn't
seek out new experiences I didn't try
new things I just happened to stumble on
to somebody who like the same stuff as
me and it's like not that wild or
anything it's very similar you know
so beause when you're writing the
one-liners yeah are you
turned on sexually or are you more
satisfied that they liked the line you
sent I yeah it's the second one it's
kind of like how geo likes to be desired
I like I like I feel like I'm desired in
the sense that I know that they're
really enjoying this you know yeah like
you gave them something that you know
that they yeah and they're yeah they're
like they're like holy [ __ ] I want this
woman yeah I do voice memos all the time
and I'm gonna pull that [ __ ] out brother
would you I want you to start a sex
hotline with that voice yo you want me
to suck dick dick sighs oh yeah hello
welcome welcome all of your fantasies
will be fulfilled actually reminded me
like Gloria Gloria I don't know I don't
know why that reminded me of that that's
the only guy that's ever done what like
they're close have you ever yeah I think
no I think what glory hole no I don't
think I would ever do that just like
gaming porn but I don't I don't think I
want to get gangbanged a lot of girls
that like that though yeah yeah it's
just the idea of not knowing who's
[ __ ] to you and like they just get to
do whatever they want down there and
like you just don't even know that Nick
they're gonna do it I don't know it's
kind of like that same thing that's nice
yeah I like that do you I think ties
into the feeling of being desired you
know absolutely no cuz like they can't
see me I'm just a hole to them
touch I forgot about that she just wants
to get hurt I'm real nasty like that
like big thing like they don't have any
connection to me emotionally they're
just a bunch of dudes getting their
rocks off their rocks off yeah but I
don't want that to happen to me in real
life it's just like your fantasies last
evil killing someone else go through
that yeah
I'm really excited we need like a we
need like a patreon short of like
y'all's boyfriend you and Jess when
you're always saying that nasty [ __ ] I
want to see Steve reacting to that I
want to see Joe reacting to Jess's [ __ ]
like I absolutely want to see that he
likes does his mouth I wanna see what
happens so do you guys ever think that
your perspective on dudes will ever
change like say it all gets normalized
and now there's like laws if they free
the the nipple on Instagram where it
becomes more normal to society to see
boobs and stuff yeah then yeah totally
because then it's not such a big deal I
think the reason it's such a big deal is
because it's been so lies and taboo
exactly your shame around it - no I
totally feel like I would be completely
fine - and the reason why I know that is
because when we go to the all women
spawn we're all naked they're like the
first time we went geo remember how I
was just like oh my god this is like I
can't I can't even yeah yeah I always
feel like you were free no girl the
first time I was just like I was like
covering myself with the towel like okay
complete shame and I was just so
uncomfortable but then I learned to
become comfortable because of everyone I
am definitely a follower
I'll follow whatever it is form like I
won't be a trendsetter so if it's like
that we're the free the nipple and we
get to go to the beach and where we
could be topless or nude or whatever
then if everyone else is doing it I'll
do it
yeah I like that tip but you're just so
open like yo I'll do it if everyone else
is doing it I'm gonna do it yeah that's
like yeah I think like yeah cuz I'm
holding it like a [ __ ] diva [ __ ]
singer like Mariah Carey and [ __ ] like
cuz we keep talking about
I'm like TIF anyway but ya know I'm like
I remember we went to the spa like I
would have had no inclination that you
were nervous to go the first time I saw
so excited and I was like I was really
nervous to go - were you nervous yeah I
was I kind of can just adapt to whatever
anyone else is feeling like so if I'm
nervous but the group is like really
casual about it I just like take on
therefore that feeling so I'm being like
oh it's really casual then similar to
like the following thing but it's not
just like logic it's not logically like
if everyone's doing it I can do it it's
more just a feeling like a vibe where
I'm like oh like the vibe is everyone's
cool with it like I guess I'm cool with
him I think the cool thing about that is
is that the going with the flow vibe it
makes you suppress your own like like
kind of irrational beliefs about like
what's okay and what's not yeah and I
think it's it's it's fair to be honest
so many of us have irrational beliefs on
different things you know and then
sometimes you just need a little push to
like do the opposite of what you think
is right and to be like oh that that was
actually not bad at all yeah I tried
anal once a little push it was like well
you know everyone's saying maybe it's
good and then maybe not a push maybe a
relax gave a little relax I actually
thought that you could keep your
virginity if you did it was not fun so
never good we kind of grazed on this and
I and I do want to if we have to close
it off on this I do want to close it off
on this but what do you so for me
someone like me with my character it's
hard for a guy to push me into doing
something I don't want to do of course
but but how would you guys um if you
guys are so strong about no I don't want
to I don't want to I don't want to in
this like man but if you like me won't
he's just sending it like you know no
yeah I'm not like that how do you do it
because it's all about like my internal
feeling and if you're like pressuring me
like that that means like you don't
respect exact my own boundaries that I
already
and I'm about setting boundaries and
about being like I need to feel 100%
comfortable and sex and all sexual
aspects of it it should be mutually
comfortable you'd never be like someone
pressuring you to do something or like
and then that's how you have regret and
shame and all that because you did
something that you knew in your heart
you didn't want to go are you weren't
comfortable doing and you did it anyway
and then now you feel guilty about it I
have to be 100% like okay I'm ready it's
my decision do you know I love it for me
it's um so I I try to set boundaries I
try to be like no this is what I like
this is what I don't like and you're not
gonna get a nude for me because that's I
not comfortable with that right I try to
do that but then I also have this other
side of me where I try to be open-minded
and say like well you know I haven't
tried this before
that's cool I'm gonna see if I like that
or not yeah that's awesome so then I'll
end up doing that but then because even
though initially I felt like no I'm not
comfortable with this but then I ended
up ignoring my own boundary and then
something else out then I end up
regretting that things online buck cool
right like you can go [ __ ] down that
sucks but you're like now for sure I
know like it's stamped on there now you
can't do that [ __ ] again yeah I think
I'm open-minded but it's I need time to
soak on it you know like to sit on it
and be like what would that feel like
would I be comfortable what would I feel
like afterwards and like run through it
in my head before being able to come to
a decision not like being pressured on
the spot like now or never
let's do it what you don't love me like
you're not gonna do it I don't like that
it's height it's like love it bullied
this [ __ ] this is like a thought that
I just had and I'm still like processing
it but it's definitely not about boys
because you're not holding it anything
about dicks I think that you know what
TIFF just said it was about pushing past
the boundary I think that
open-mindedness is about like there are
boundaries that we've created on our own
base on our own experiences boundaries
that we've built to protect ourselves
but then there are also boundaries that
society places on us and then boundaries
that our environment or external forces
place on us I think open-mindedness is
about leave your boundaries that you've
created through your experiences leave
those there because you have those for a
reason they reflect you but if it's
boundary that you feel like you did not
create or set up then maybe it's time to
just like get tests you know it makes no
sense against your own moral code you're
like wait this is fine yeah yeah that
makes sense yeah totally yeah it's like
how like when marijuana was illegal and
same thing where I don't smoke pot but I
always thought it should be legal
because like people it doesn't hurt
anybody
it's like alcohol has way more
consequences like to me it should be
legal even though society says no this
is a drug in dare they're like you're
gonna get addicted to pot no this isn't
on drugs yeah it's like okay you know
personally I can't smoke weed because it
makes me super paranoid I tried it once
it was like nope can't do it but that's
not that shouldn't be enforced upon
everybody like for a lot of people it
helps them it like I like helps them
medically it helps them like calm down
it does the same thing for them that a
glass of wine does for me and then
people are allergic to alcohol and it's
not fair that they can't imbibe on
anything yeah but then so that's like
the my boundaries versus society's
boundaries it's like there's a law
against this but I don't understand it
and now it's not there but I was totally
okay with people like smoking pot around
me when it was illegal yeah yeah and I
think that's kind of the same the same
thing you're talking about yeah like
your rules versus society's rules yeah I
think that's dope thank you guys cuz
like everyone who is like no I'm never
gonna send I'm like [ __ ] I send them all
the time but no one made me feel like
[ __ ] but yeah that's really anything for
me that was that was really it cuz for
you it's like oh you want oh it's you
person to be it does something for me
but it's on the negative side yeah like
it's yeah it's not worth it for you yeah
it's definitely not worth it
well damn this is a good ass discussion
yeah I love it
or being so I love that we had different
opinions and everything yeah I need more
girls to talk about news like girls okay
alright so that concludes our hey [ __ ]
podcast I do want to say a special thank
you to our sponsors stitch fix so make
sure to get started today with stitch
fix calm slash b tch and get an extra
25% off when you keep everything in your
box
that stitch fixed calm slash b tch okay
stitch fix calm slash b tch and
hellofresh so remember you get $40 off
your first month of fellow fresh go to
hell afresh calm slash b tch eighty and
enter code b tch eight zero again for
$80 off your first month of hello fresh
go to hell afresh calm slash b tch
eighty enter b tch eighty thank you
everybody
there's more [ __ ] oh wow more [ __ ]
just came in more [ __ ] just came next
next episode